قال رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه الامريكيه
الجنرال مارك ميني انه سيكون من الصعب دحر
القوات الروسيه خلال السنه الحاليه من كل
جزء احتلته في اوكرانيا واضاف في مؤتمر
صحفي مشترك مع وزير الدفاع الامريكي في
قاعده رامشتاين الامريكيه في المانيا ظفر
ان الحرب في اوكرانيا يجب ان تنتهي على
طاوله المفاوضات على غرار العديد من
الحروب في العالم واكدانا الدعم لاوكرانيا
سيستمروا ما استمرت الحرب
من جانبه قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي
ليس هناك اي اعلان جديد بشان تزويده في
الدبابات غير التي تلقتها من بولندا ودول
الاخرى موضحا ان القوات الاوكرانيه تتلقى
حاليا تدريبا على طريقه استخدام مدرعات
برادليه الامريكيه في الاشتباك والمناره